si fa male adesso è un altro paio di
maniche eto'o vogliono perchè tiscali
tutto sto pregando perché la domanda è
perché volete farci fare queste cose
allora questa per sé molto carina mamma
perché mi chiedono di fare judo e ciapi
panni
sai cos'è no hai bisogno di un pacco di
marshmallows e devi riuscire a metterli
in bocca il più possibile oggi però a
ognuno a per ogni marshmallow di miss il
boca devi dire chubby panini
sabbi panni di jackie panetti c'è chi
parla di infami
[Risate]
disgustoso
certo i pallini quanti sto sei capi
famiglia
[Musica]
[Risate]
si è capito giorni con di fatto sono
buoni 889 basta da parente semini
marshmallows fanno schifo cosa mangiarli
summit anni di rendere veloce tranquilla
nessun timore
[Musica]
tutto in ballo charmet anche l'altra
mancio esiste vista a trovare almeno
c'era un po di soldi donne
[Musica]
prima la guardo dallo schermo è male che
non voglio vedere il bel po di persone
mi hanno chiesto invece nel romanzo di
intra fine nell'altro video mi hanno
chiesto di parlare del romanzo un minimo
ne parlero veramente un minimo un minimo
sindacale
allora è un fantasy è un fantasy pieno
di suspense anche un thriller ma dà
anche degli spunti di grande riflessione
perché di base però silvia su fantasy
potrebbe piacere questo ambìto di due
boe tanto si è scarafoni bella mano
sulla capitale anche se avessi scritto
col mio culo se la carta igienica
forse sarebbe stata una grande opera
comunque è solo 8 maggio per girare
scrivere visto che i capelli lunghi
prova farti codini stile pippi
calzelunghe vincendo mame l'ass
mi scrive descrivi quanto fa schifo la
scuola utilizzando una metafora che
nessuno si aspetta
siccome qui c'è mio fratello che ho
della scuola larino che lui e ricoh poi
descrivere la squadra con con una
metafora che nessuno allora io la mia
ora la scuola è come un anno la scuola è
come un anno quando le fare la cacca
se la cache dura difficile da spingere
da tirar fuori ma questa specie di
groppo silurare un immenso di piombo
allora però il sollievo una volta fatto
sarà maggiore anzi vi sentirete bene con
voi stessi se invece da skuola.net
recata via come se fossero lo score un
marshmallow dopo la cia b challenge non
ti soddisfa e te ne pentirai per la dia
ha a tuscania che vogliate il gran è
vero ho capito cosa voglio dire si
capisce mamma e si ho capito ma una
c'era di meglio la scuola
[Musica]
la scuola è come l'inverno ma la cosa
migliore senza ormai ho deciso che il
guglielmo tell e tutti quanti miei video
saranno sul primo canale perché già
fatico a mettere i video nel primo
canale a premi un secondo canale non ha
senso ho capito il primo canale alla
fine il secondo canale sono sempre io
solamente che in uno stop più attento al
contenuto dei video e quant'altro
nell'altro invece sono più tranquillo
giusto e collo clea più colloquiale
perché non possono convivere le due cose
ci vediamo alla prossima convivenza ci
vediamo al prossimo inizio di un nuovo
percorso parallelo come binari di un
treno ecco noi siamo tutti quanti
insieme in un treno ma senza altre hanno
mai non si potranno mai magma
ma se non solo due binari un treno non
ha un binario un treno a due binari e
questi due binari saranno i video alzato
la mente parlino
io sto facendo una promessa di fedeltà
pazzesca e tu stai a guardare il lille
con lo schermo perché sfalsato non lo so
più che dire perché sono fuori fuoco
comunque questa promessa io ve la faccio
avremo questi due binari ma nello stesso
tragitto ragazzi uno che porterà i video
che voi avete sempre conosciuto in
questo in questo canale è un altro che
invece permetterà più libertà è al
limite se vi fa schifo il video che è
quello di un pochino più tranquillo qui
cresce l'uso chiudete e ne sono certo
poi arriverà quell'altro pare che stia
parlando una lingua straniera dal
movimento delle labbra ancora mamma stai
guardando qualcosa è perché non si in
sincronia
ciao